翻訳: Harue Mori
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
みなさんの中で
トイレットペーパーの芯を
ご存じない方っていらっしゃいますか？
いらっしゃいませんよね
よかったです
芯を知らないという方がいらっしゃったら
そこからご説明をしなければなりませんので
私は この芯を使って
アート作品を作っています
芯はカットしてつなげるんですけれども
そのカットした芯を繋げるために
使っているのは
市販で販売している
グルーガンという
プラスチックみたいなのを溶かして
溶接するものを使っています
私のアート創作には
３つの決まりごとがあります
ひとつ目は
芯に色を塗らないということ
芯には実に いろんな種類があるんですが
茶色かったり 白かったり
あとは「ありがとうございました」とか
文字が書いてあるものもあるんですが
そういったものを素材として
そのまま使用しています
そしてふたつ目は
芯の裁断方法が決まっているということです
芯は潰した状態から裁断するのですが
真ん中から このように
カットするように決めています
そして 最大の大きさが２分の１
最小の大きさが16分の１分割と決めています
３つ目は ゴミを出さないように
創作をするということです
リサイクルアート ということもあるんですが
先ほどの芯の分割のところでも
測って切ってしまうとゴミが出てしまうので
なるべく分割法で芯を切るようにしています
そして それらの芯を組み合わせて
アートを作っているんですけれども
最大は15メートルから
そして 最小は手のひらサイズのものまで
そういったものを
インスタレーションアート
という手法でお見せしています
インスタレーションとは
現代アートの手法のひとつで
空間全体をアートとして
とらえていただくものなんです
なので 例えば 場所が変わったりとかすると
同じ作品を展示しても
見え方や感じ方が変わるようになっています
私がアートを創作するきっかけになったのは
ある友人からの依頼でした
１ヶ月間 お寺の本堂の横のスペースで
何か作品を展示してほしい
私はデザインの仕事をしているので
友人は多分そこの場所にあった何かを
展示してくれるんじゃないかなと
思ってくださったんですね
デザインの仕事柄 私は
ホームページとか チラシなどを作ったりして
日々 新しいものを常に作り出しています
その頃の私は
そういって新しいものを作り出しては
破棄していく というそのことに
とても違和感を感じていました
そしてせっかく機会をいただいたんだから
新しいものから
新しいものを作りだすのではなくて
今あるものから
なにか新しいものとかを作り出せないかなぁ
と考え始めたんです
それが
私がトイレットペーパーの芯に
興味を持つきっかけになったのですが
それはまさに
「ニュートンのリンゴ」でした
みなさん ニュートンはご存じですか？
ご存知ですよね
私よりずっと有名な方なので
ニュートンは リンゴが木から落ちることで
万有引力を発見したとされています
ですが本当にそうなのでしょうか？
リンゴがぽとんと木から落ちるのを見て
「バンユーインリョクー！」
という形にひらめいたわけではないと
思うんですよね
毎日毎日
引力について研究をしていたからこそ
リンゴが木から落ちるというその自然なことに
反応できたのではないでしょうか
私のトイレットペーパー芯リサイクルアートも
それと同じです
日々トイレに行けば
意識しなくても目に入るトイレットペーパー
そして 交換するたびに必ず手に取る
トイレットペーパーの芯
そしてある時 ふとその芯を手に取って
思ったんです
芯って
ペーパーがなくなれば
ただゴミになるだけなのに
その紙はすごく丈夫なものでできています
そして
形状も素晴らしく 丸くて
同じものが揃ってるんですね
その芯を 改めて手に取ったときに
芯ってなんて完璧なんだろうと思ったんです
この完璧な芯を使って
なにかできないかなぁと思い始めたんですよ
それで私は 世の中に
トイレットペーパーの芯を使って
アートを作っている
そういう作品って
どんなものがあるのかなぁと思って
インターネットで
まず調べたんですね
すると
工作とかクラフトのようなものは
たくさんあったんですが
例えば個展で展示していたりとか
あとは アートとして作品として
作られているものが ひとつもなかったんです
トイレットペーパーの芯で
アートを作っているアーティストが
世界中にひとりもいなかったんです
私は そのことに気づいたときに
びっくりしたのと同時に
なんかおもしろいことに気づいたなぁ
と思ったんです
それから私は実際に
アート創作を行うのですが
なんせこう
前例がまったくないものですから
全て 自分でいろんなことを
考えなければなりません
驚いたり
感動したり
悩んだりしたことがたくさんありました
最初の頃
「リサイクルペーパーアート」
という言い方をしていたら
来場者の方に
「これ何の紙で作ってるんですか？」
って言われたことがあります
最初から 芯に色を塗らない
というふうに決めていたので
見れば芯だと分かると思ってたんですね
それから私の肩書きは
「トイレットペーパー芯
リサイクルアーティスト」
という とても長いものになりました
2010年に マレーシアの
アートフェスティバルに呼ばれたときに
そこの現地のデザイン学校の生徒たちと
作品を作ったことがあります
その際に
私は全然英語が喋れなくて
でも３つの決まりごとを守るように
通訳をしていただき
そしてあとはもう
身振り手振りのジェスチャーで
２週間かけて
作品を作り上げることができました
知らない土地で 言葉も通じない中で
素晴らしい作品が作り上げられたときに
私はとても感動したことを覚えています
そのときに思ったんです
トイレットペーパーの芯って
先進国であれば
そう珍しいものではないんですよ
そして その芯で作るアートは
年齢や性別
人種や言語が変わっても
比較的に 受け入れやすく
感動しやすいんですね
アートを身近に感じながら
感動していただけるんです
でもそんな身近に感じるアートだからこそ
悩んだことがありました
あるとき こう言われたことがあります
「なんだぁ・・・
芯を切って 貼ってるだけじゃないか
僕にもできる」
あとは「きゃあ すごいステキー！
これどうやって作ってるんだろう？」
と言って
パシャパシャパシャとケイタイで撮影して
どうなってるのかな ああなってるのかな
「すいません！
これ どうやって作ってるんですか？
教えてください！」
と言われたこともあります
感動してくださるのは
とても嬉しいことなんですが
私はそのとき
表面的な感動しか伝わっていないなぁ
と思って
すごく なぜかモヤモヤしちゃったんですね
それで
私はアートを通じて
いったい何が伝えたいんだろう
と思ったんです
それから私は 感動するだけではなくて
それらを共感し
そして 共有していただくことで
その感情を継続させていきたいと
考え始めました
アートを見て感動する
そして ゴミとか 例えばリサイクル品
というものがアートになっていく
ということに共感していただく
そこから ご自身もお家に帰ってから
雑紙とかトイレットペーパーの芯を
リサイクルに出す
もしくは 私の場合は有志の方に
芯を集めていただいてますので
そういった活動に参加していただく
そういうことを共有していただく
それらを継続していただくことで
日々 思い出す機会を持っていただいて
また感動していただくんですね
そのぐるぐる廻るということで
私の個展のタイトルは決まっているんですが
『廻ルモノコト』
人とものが廻るという意味で
というタイトルにしています
そしてそれが私のアートコンセプトと
なりました
私はよく こう言われます
「山田さんだからできるんだよ」
「山田さんには才能があるから」
「山田さんは特別だから」
「センスがあるから」
でもご覧のとおり
私には 目が３つあるわけでもありませんし
１日に30時間
時間があるわけでもありません
みなさんと同じ
細胞レベルでは同じ人間です
でも違うところがあると言えば
2010年から
日々 芯を潰して
それをストックし
そこから取り出して
芯をカットする
そういった単純な作業を繰り返してきました
だからこそ私は
何の変哲もないトイレットペーパーの芯を
特別なものにすることができたんだと思います
毎日 関心があることとか
あと 興味があること
それらを考える時間を
頭の中で考える時間を作る
その考えたことを行動に移してみる
そして そのふたつのことを
日々繰り返してみる
そういった この３つの
特別でもなんでもないことが
特別なことにつながっていくんです
万有引力を発見したニュートンも
リンゴが落ちたことに気づかなければ
もしかしたら
引力を発見できなかったかもしれません
でも私もニュートンも
毎日の生活の中で
大きなアンテナを張り巡らせて
そこでキャッチした小さな気づきを
ひとつひとつ行動に移していった結果なんです
私は今
「トイレットペーパー芯リサイクルアート」
というリンゴを手にしています
あなたはリンゴを手にしていますか？
特別なことは
当たり前の中に存在します
そのことを意識して 毎日を過ごせたら
あなたにも 世界でただひとつの
リンゴが見つかるかもしれません
アートを通じてまたどこかで
みなさんにお会いできますことを
楽しみにしております
（拍手）